حاله لحظه الوداع الاسطوره الارجنتيني
ليونيل ميسي يشارك في المونديال الاخير له
حاملا اماله وامال شعب التانجو في احتضان
الكاس والفوز باللقب في مونديال قطر 2022
للمره الاولى منذ عام 86 مسيره حافله
للنجم ميسي حصد خلالها ما يقرب من 40 لقب
مع الانديه التي لعب لصالحها ومع المنتخب
الارجنتيني لكن حتى اليوم خزانه ميسي
الكرويه لا تزالوا فارغه من اهم لقب في
عالم المستدير لقب بطل كاس العالم ميسي
المولود في الرابع والعشرين من يونيو عام
1987 واحد من افضل الاساطير الكرويه في
العالم هذا وحده سبع جوائز من الكره
الذهبيه وهو رقم قياسي لم يكسره اي لاعب
اخر على مرسي لكن في الداخل الارجنتيني
الغالبيه العظمى من محبي كره القدم يضعون
ميسي في المرتبه الثانيه بعد الاسطوره
مارادونا السبب وراء هذه المرتبه تحقيق
لقبه كاس العالم عام
1986 منتخب الارجنتين شاركت في نهائيات
كاس العالم 17 مره وفاز باللقب مرتين في
مونديال 78 و 86 كما حل وصيفا البطل 3
مرات
اشعر براحه البال لانني حققت الحلم الذي
حرمت منه مره عديده من الصعب جدا للفوز
بكاس العالم او كوبا امريكا في الوقت الذي
لم يقدر فيه ما فعلناه ركزوا فقط على
حقيقه اننا لم نحقق كاس العالم هذه
الانتصارات المتلاحقه توجت الارجنتين باول
القابها الكبيره خلال ما يقرب من 30 عاما
عندما رفع الفريق كاس كوبا امريكا العمل
الماضي كاس العالم مسابقه صعبه للغايه يجب
ان تحدث العديد من الاشياء للفوز بها
الكثير من الامور قد تجعلنا خارج البطوله
كما ان هناك منتخبات اخرى لديها نفس رغبه
في الفوز باللقب وتبلي بلا ان حسنا
بعد صيام طويل دام سته وثلاثين سنه فهل
يفعلها ميسي